[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to a new
let's play this is the stuff I'm
recording well in that comic-con so this
is all pre-recorded if you leave a
comment I won't know about it I don't
know I won't be able to get any hints or
anything but anyway I was gonna do a cry
for your custom story but I'm running
out of time of it it kept crashing on me
so I couldn't get to work so I'm still
running through this art this is the
Attic chapter 1 and I have chapter 2
lined up by Seth one four six six and
jetliner X Derek lives with his mother
his father is said to still be serving
the country making some sort of medicine
that can heal a human being via drinking
some sort of substance Derek has never
been allowed past a second floor where
his bedroom is his father's workshop
takes up everything from the Fleur third
floor and the Attic the story begins
with Derek reminiscing about his past
when him and his father used to sit on
the deck outside of his bedroom as a
young child
Derek realizes now that he is almost
ready to make a family and move into his
own mansion because everyone moves into
their own mansion when they grow up he
should find out what is going on and why
his dad has been missing for 16 years
what and why his mother has never said
anything oh the player.you
begins the story when Derek comes to
this realization he wakes up one day
like where's my daddy and must continue
through the adventure revealing secrets
of your family's dark past that will
forever tear them apart so long as
nothing tears them apart first
[Laughter]
hahaha can't anyone proofread it's a
simple paragraph anyway I'm gonna go
crazy if I don't go crazy let's get into
it let's just go let's just go it was
highly rated let's just go pro Frankie
please there we are
Oh Oh interesting
hello father and I used to sit out here
when mother was tending to the guests I
was only 2 so all the things that were
going on or a fading memory sorry all
the things that we're going on pause are
a fading memory pause but I remember him
saying one day Derek one day you will
want to find out everything you are
already adventurous but no some things
should remain just remain in the dark
because I was only 2 my response with a
mix of gargling mumbles and no one
understood my father looked down at me
and finished with good boy I know you
understand and somehow he remembers
exactly what he said word for word
oh whatever
just scare me scare me if you can you in
your mansion now how did you get in here
if there's gonna be diabolical monsters
pop it on the door I know how to play
game just put a chair in my handle let's
be done with it
God why what what hey Joe what what uh
fine whatever
I don't need it anyway so tough on my
own tinder box
aha I knew it nope sixteen years have
passed
I've never formally met my father you
talked to him when you were two Oh the
only time I knew him was when I was two
my father has not been seen for 16 years
mother's started drinking pretty heavily
five years ago 11 years after the father
left so couldn't have been related she
always tells me that
her that father wrote letters home he's
considered a scientist among some you're
either considered a sign that they're
mine he was called into the line of duty
who the scientists line of duty to make
chemical weapons for the war nobody has
ever made a weapon without something
going wrong
let's just hope I see him in human form
when he returned from the war what are
there for would he be monster form
probably I got to pick up a key to that
door really I locked myself in whatever
bring it on
hello who's here bring it on oh hello
the following trophy is awarded to Ellis
Jackson for the pursuit of inventing
laudanum a cash reward of one hundred
thousand into Elysee Jackson his wife
Libby R Jackson along with their some
son Derek s Jackson upon completion of
the serum Oh No that sound it came from
the Attic fast push smash BAM boom look
at this sandy and not Donna
it's big I gotta explore it before you
go to the Attic
ah seems perfectly normal I totally know
where the Attic is hello hello where all
my mates I'm some rich dude right there
come on man
where's all my workers hello oh hello
oil oil I boil one of the rare times
during the Box rare times that they
actually fill me up with oil before they
set me on my way
was this the Attic hang on I want to go
downstairs first if I can I don't know
I'm doing dammit all right fine I knew
it
ah all right to the mr. what come on
oh there we go all right there we are
maybe I could use the key on the other
one I don't know I don't know whatever
Britton steps and hand steps hey what
the hell
who's playing my piano everything in
this house is mine do lots of keys
assistant it has come to my attention
that a great leap forward in the
technologies of medicine must be made I
have gathered information on herbs blood
and everything else i could ever oh this
is his father that could never be
possible to heal a human being let it be
known that I Ellis Jackson will not rest
until this potion is made so far I have
a working title of laudanum but that
will most likely change when this
project is finally done I will continue
to document my findings and eventually
come up with a greatest invention of the
1800s I will go down in history of
course everyone knows that laudanum is
just an opiate liquid suspended opiate
that they used as a painkiller and
highly addictive back in those times so
it's not really a magical healing
targets just just opium in liquid form
you take like a drop you'd put drops on
your tongue if anyone's seen the show
Deadwood you know that all right let's
see if this key goes in that thing right
cheer right chair yep
there's someone huh that's scary
not scary nope oh yeah what da hell
today is the big day
oh no is the decision today is the big
day
Ellis is letting me test the first
version of the potion he said it was
totally stable and would not harm me I'm
very excited to see if it would work but
scared because the only way to tell if
it works is it I must be injured so we
plan to take the knife and cut of small
gash in my arm about two inches long
quarter inch deep I know it will hurt
and I am really worried cuz I'm a giant
baby but I have to trust in Ellis Oh God
is it two inch cut my goodness and he
has been working on this for about six
months
day and night I bet this will work okay
it's 9 o'clock I need to get it to the
workshop and now you're dead oh yeah
there's your skull hello hello BAM whomp
[ __ ] yeah God lie down um I'm just
gonna slog this stuff down ah it's been
five hours I can't feel anything in my
body and it's called me and to amputate
my arm as it was M II D it has
immediately become infected and has lost
all blood no how does one arm lose all
blood we are going to replace it with a
metal prosthetic until we can get a real
one in real one in god save me at least
my sacrifice was for science eh eh who
writes a
who's gonna read your freakin notes that
you gotta go good thing Hey ah ah the
old elbow bub
maybe I'm being a little too skeptical
as I'm playing this cousins where I
should get lost I should get lost in the
rich story hello how did I hear that oh
yeah don't know how I heard that all the
way from downstairs but whatever hello
anybody here so brightly lit well yeah
well hello tinderbox give me all of your
[ __ ] gimme take it's all mine anyway my
mansion right my inherence it did did it
it was my mom didn't say that she died
yeah hello hi dad
oops hello come here you look a lot like
this guy I know from this I benefit
outweigh what's gonna happen I read it
had the following recipe for laudanum a
working invention based in the United
Kingdom description of the medicine
laudanum is an herb organic based
substance set is entered through the
body via injection with a needle or
ingesting the fluid by swallow it or
it's opium the medicine is designed for
healing major and minor wounds or it's
opium ingredients two quarts of human
blood or opium croup a divine opium one
pipe of acid of the Damned oh I thought
that painting was gonna change I
could've sworn it like you gonna read no
no no okay fine
whoa that venoms
nevermind nothing happened I was not
startled by the mannequin my mannequins
mannequins do not scare me hello what
kind of level design is this what kind
of house design is this who would it who
did this who did this they deserve to be
flogged this is the worst house I've
ever been I'm not even going to try to
understand this there anything in here
hello hello no nothing nothing for no
one nothing for no one nowhere know how
hello Oh big room this is um no it's
plugged in your douche nozzle whatever
it's in my phone was that a battery
which I'm using first timer but it's
plugged in right now otherwise deals
turn into bucks hmm anything hang on
that was more it was more to this level
I'm gonna explore hello
hello dammit was that it
no this one no those okay that was it up
the stairs I go can't see the timer
phone douche see oh yes all very lovely
yes alright your mistake giving me a
chair and it's clearly obvious ambush oh
never mind I panic for nothing
apparently
alright living long moving on my way 10
the box
awesome awesome
broom [ __ ] I guess it's who did that
bar honey I'm not gonna even like Wow
what's this dead body doing here it's so
weird I don't even know nope
dad what's going on what is there dead
gun nope ow my face all right Oh
all right then
oh there's a head there okay it looks
like the amount for Agrippa all right
actually I'm gonna cut it here thank you
guys so much for watching and as always
see you in the next part and a reminder
I can't see your comments at the moment
I won't be able to I this is all in one
big playthrough so I won't be able to
take your hints for any things that I
need to do so thanks again for watching
and as always I'll see you in the next
part bye bye